there's something really incredible
happening so there's over a billion
people who have no access to energy
whatsoever across the world 620 million
of them here in Africa it costs about
$1,500 to connect each household up to
the grid if you're gonna wait for it it
takes about nine years on average I mean
that feels like a lifetime when you
trying to make that happen that's kind
of unbelievable and it's also
unacceptable so let's do something about
it the light bulb comes from this idea
that you have an energy system that's
made up of the ideas of Tesla and the
ideas of Thomas Edison there was an
evolution that said it's not just about
the light bulb it's about the whole
system the whole energy system that goes
with that light bulb and what happened
in that Gilded Age was the creation of
an industrial system that every country
around the world has now started to
emulate so to get to the appliances you
need to have power stations from power
stations you need to have infrastructure
and that infrastructure then takes you
to the point of having electricity and
you get to to the light bulbs and the
appliances that we all take for granted
but the amazing thing in ways that
there's a revolution happening in the
villages and towns all around us here in
East Africa and the revolution is an
echo of the cell phone revolution it's
wireless and that revolution is about
solar and it's about distributed solar
photons are wireless they fall on every
rooftop and they generate enough power
to be sufficient for every household
need so that's an incredible thing it's
also a problem with it up until now the
technology hasn't been there to make it
happen and the mindset has been that we
have to have the grid to provide
industrial growth and let countries
develop and create jobs and and
industrialize so we've gotten ourselves
to a point where actually the
the costs of building these grids and
following that pattern of development
are really unsustainable if you add up
the deficits that all of the utilities
run in Africa sub-saharan Africa you get
to a number of 21 billion dollars every
year to maintain that system and keep it
going
so an extraordinary amount of resource
that's been put into creating a system
that ultimately will have to wait a very
long time for and when it comes it often
doesn't come with sufficient robustness
to allow us to go down that path to
development so what a what a shame but
here's what's happening and here's the
opportunity that I think we should all
get excited about so there's a group of
companies that have been chipping away
at this problem over the last 10 years
and this group of companies have
recognized a reality that there's a
great big nuclear reactor up there in
the sky and that Africa is more endowed
with that solar power that comes from
the sky the Sun than almost any other
continent so the opportunity has come to
convert some of that solar power
wireless power into energy at the
household level and three things have
happened at the same time
first the costs of solar productivity
have come down so putting a panel on
your roof and generating power from it
that cost has absolutely collapsed at
the last 30 years and it's gone down by
95% second the appliance network so the
group of appliances that we've all
gotten used to we all want and we all
need will see as part of our everyday
lives that give us health and security
those appliances have come down and cost
so if you take the LED light bulb for
example a very simple thing five years
ago that well they're now 85% less than
they were five years ago and their
efficiency when you compare them to an
incandescent bulb the light bulb I
showed him the previous slide is
incredible ten times they give you ten
times the amount of light and they last
thirty times as long and then the last
thing has happened is of course the cell
phone revolution so we're piggybacking
off the
a revolution and we can now make
decentralized customers make small
payments for bits of equipment and
appliances we're actually there now
affordable and we can pay them off over
a daily or weekly schedule so this is an
incredible change in the economy that's
happening and it's really opened up
something very very innovative so I'm
going to introduce you to a lady I met
with last week and I'm Susan may not
look like it but Susan is a
representative of a twenty seven billion
dollar market twenty seven billion
dollars is what people like Susan spend
every year on cell phone charging
flashlights batteries and kerosene to
light their homes so Susan is a proud
owner of a small solar system it's a kit
rather than a planetary thing so a small
solar system and her small solar system
allows her to have a couple of
lightbulbs and she's made this
transmission this jump from kerosene
into light just four or five lights and
a radio is fantastic and she talks about
it she talks about her kids doing
homework at night and because she has
light I'm not sure what the kids feel
about that she talks about she talks
about the fact that she can go out at 4
a.m. and look after the cows and she's
not so worried but she also talks about
this little twinkle in her eye she talks
about how light turns her house into a
home
at night she's not scared of her own
house at night because it has light in
it and I thought that was amazing so
Susan does something that many customers
of these companies that are talked about
dude and she forces us to innovate she
challenges companies say well I've got
the radio and the lights you know I'd
like a TV I'd like to entertain their
decayed you know me and my kids and then
I'd like to have some hair clippers my
kids need to come a kids hair and I'd
love to have a fridge and she's coined
something that the energy world is
really hungry to do the idea that she's
coined as is the energy ladder starts
again with a light bulb the light bulb
is an idea that we can get our kids to
do homework and very cheap about five
dollars
and we can get it distributed but then
let's go up from there this is a kitten
Susan has four light bulbs Radio maybe a
little flashlight a little solar panel
on the roof and then let's go up again
we can get maybe at about five hundred
dollars the previous clip was maybe 150
again paid for overtime two years to pay
it all off you can get the TV so the
light bulbs and the TV and you start to
ask yourself so where's this headed is
this headed here you know where we can
have distributed systems with the right
infrastructure to provide power for our
hospitals and our schools and really how
far can this go and this is the mindset
shift that I think is really exciting
how far can this go
could we get up to here yeah this is the
conceptual design for one of the world's
biggest factories designed to be fully
solar-powered and fully off-grid maybe
we can get back so there's a generation
of these companies that are that are out
there doing this work and creating
thousands of jobs creating selling tens
of thousands of these solar systems so
bringing tens of thousands of families
into light and tackling that big 1
billion dollar problem that I talked
about at the beginning and really
innovating and what they're doing is
they're not only energy companies
they're also credit finance companies so
they're bringing people into an economy
their retail and the plant retail
companies so they're taking products out
to people in the connecting markets and
their appliance companies so they're
developing extraordinary products that
are very efficient and very cheap so an
extraordinary thing is happening out
there that some that's worth recognizing
and where does it take us from a
governmental perspective from a social
perspective it takes us out to two
really big goals we aspire towards
energy access for everybody and we
aspire towards a low-carbon economy
fully functioning
low-carbon economy and we're getting to
the point where we're seeing the fully
functioning low-carbon economy is not
just about getting people onto the grid
it's about getting people onto
electricity and doing it in a way that's
really big nerf ID so what us all to
picture it for a moment really picture
what this could mean an energy system
that's not just about subsistence power
getting the family off the kerosene but
it's actually the full suite of
appliances and tools and productivity
that we've all gotten used to so
actually energy at a scale that can
drive industrial development and it's
the ability to have powerful tools it's
the ability to be productive in our
households as a farmer or as a carpenter
or as a tailor and get your businesses
to work and bring you into the economy
and I was working again a couple of days
ago with a farmer just outside of
Nairobi small fields and he has an
irrigation pump that's runoff soda and
he was bragging about how much of a
difference it made to his productivity
when we were listening to him we were
asking ourselves at what point will it
be that actually you'll be charging an
electric scooter off your rooftop and
taking your crops to market on with
mobility that you've charged yourself
using your own power and that's an
extraordinary thing that's happening and
if you listen to Susan Lee listen to
Frances you get to this point where you
say these guys have this extraordinary
sense of dignity about the way they're
achieving their power the sense of
ownership and the sense of pride and I'm
gonna flip into a little tiny video clip
which is from a distributor of one of
these companies that I'm talking about
and he puts her better than anyone I've
ever heard it so let's just listen to it
so if if it does happen now we get to a
point where every home has their own
independence wild energy that will give
us the democracy that's it and everybody
has that choice and everybody knows when
they want to switch it off when the one
to switch it on whether the one to sell
access and whether the one who stole it
that freedom getting back into the
answer is brilliant right that was
Martin and he has a really wonderful
turn of phase and what a sense of vision
that he he captures so picture that for
a moment
every household a proud producer as well
as consumer of energy the ability to
generate power to share power to sell
power all coming from your own
generating asset seeing on your own
property maybe even think about
crowdsourcing with your neighbors the
grid from the ground up rather than
waiting for the government to bring it
from the top down so in Africa we have
this extraordinary opportunity right now
an extraordinary opportunity to change
the world and create an energy system
that everybody will be jealous of and
everybody will look to us as the
innovators of and that's the democracy
of energy thank you very much question
so I mean it's it's a really exciting
vision help us understand what are the
key roadblocks right now like what could
make this go faster so the first one I
think is is really the intermittency of
solar power so you've got the problem is
that the Sun only shines for 12 hours a
day so you've got darkness for 12 hours
a day and we need to have storage
solutions that are better to help us
take us down that path so storage is
really one second and those prices
they're coming there those prices are
coming down very quick second the
appliance set so the appliance that
needs to get more efficient than it
needs to get more diverse we need to do
more of
that we in Africa want to do with the
appliance set DC appliances DC
appliances and I think there's a real
opportunity there Chris I think the
opportunity is that we could shift some
of these 21 billion dollars of subsidies
that governments are spending on on the
current electricity system and we could
promote are indeed here in Africa to
create some of these products to be some
of these entrepreneurs and make this
happen there so create this new system
here and some of the companies
themselves I mean there's plenty of
demand there what what since what's
holding them back from supplying that
demand I mean some of them talk about
they they would like to sell 10x what
they can courage yourself so for many of
these capitals it's that markets don't
price consumer risk very well and
particularly in markets like ours in
emerging markets and here in Africa so
there's not enough working capital
coming into this space because the big
finance here's a look at this space and
they say well I don't know how to price
that risk so I'm gonna stay away from it
and that's really holding a lot of these
companies back well it's incredibly
exciting to picture what what could
happen here I mean in my mind this might
be the biggest leap frog of them all and
thank you for all you're doing and thank
you for sharing that vision
[Applause]